today I want to tie it so the title
changed a little bit from the the bio
because I was wearing my research
statement I was thinking about this idea
of budget it's more about really what
I'm going to talk about is the fact that
we put a bunch of stuff about ourselves
online and how we can use it to
understand ourselves it's not really a
big data story it's about a story this
is a story today about making meaning
and this is work that I've done with a
lot of students at Cornell a lot of
undergrads some grad students few other
faculty members right so when I say I
are we right remember there's like you
know 38 people or whatever who sort of
went into the the making of this sausage
I'm about to present all right so on to
sausage some of these people are sitting
in this very room all right so uh the
the initial story is about data online
this should be not surprising to you we
put pictures online we have lots of
pieces of our lives recorded in facebook
and email in blogs and other discussion
forum right most of you probably do a
good amount of this some of you probably
don't for privacy reasons that's okay
too but on balance right pieces of the
record of our lives are showing up and
in most of these systems right the
system is designed to privilege the now
because in social media what people want
is to be aware of the friends right and
because companies know that if there's
not fresh content people tend not to
come back and so what they do is they
take these two old data and they kind of
put it down on the screen and then you
never see it again right you as the
person created the data and mostly your
friends as people who interact with the
data never never look at it again right
other people look at it all right
companies look at it right researchers
look at it and and in fact I've done a
bunch of this kind of stuff and I call
this this perspective data as a window
right where people from the outside
based on the traces of your activity
online or maybe your phone or whatever
else you're wearing that sort of tracks
information about you I can look through
that and sort of get a picture of you
right if I'm a system right so this one
up on the left is a system I built back
in the day called suggest pot so just
about looks at what you edited in
Wikipedia um to sort of get an idea of
what you're interested in it knows
something about the Wikipedia community
as well it knows that there are certain
kinds of
work in Wikipedia Wikipedia has articles
they need expanded they need to be put
into a format that's more wiki like
links between articles in the
encyclopedia need to be made and it sort
of takes its knowledge of you and it's
knowledge of the community's needs and
puts them together to recommend items
recommend articles that you'd be
interested in helping to edit right so
the system by being smarter about you
helps Wikipedia maybe helps you a little
bit by making it easier for you to find
something to do but mostly the system is
smart right over here this is some work
that was done by some colleagues at
cornell michael mason scott golder this
is a picture of world happiness what
they did was they said oh people sort of
express how they're feeling on Twitter a
lot why don't we go collect half a
billion tweets segregated by continent
that's what the four different colored
regions are do it by our the day because
Scott's really interested in temporal
rhythms and because temporal rhythms
actually say something about our lives
right they shape the ways that we we
feel right you know that 1230 at night
studying thing is a lot different from
like that twelve thirty in the afternoon
after lunch I'm a little tired listening
to a talk thing and these things
actually affect how we interact and
based on the fact that a lot of data is
on Twitter what they thought was well we
can actually look at the world's mood
right and so you know people get really
kind of you know your negative feelings
actually dip really well here early in
the morning which is weird and positive
feelings go way up right people are
happiest for some definition of happy
that involves what a computer can
process by looking at the words in your
tweet right and for some definition of
the world right you'll notice that this
red bar that represents the u.s. is very
thin compared to this giant green bar
that represents Africa because there's
not nearly as many tweets there right
now right and so we're getting these
kind of biased samples of data but we're
still getting data that can let us look
at things that are happening you know as
researchers to try to understand human
behaviors right we can look through this
window of the data and think oh I can
learn something right and so systems can
learn something
about the things that we do online and
researchers can learn something about
the things that we do online but neither
of them actually um helps the people
themselves who created these data
normally and that's what I'm really
interested in which is personal data as
a mirror helping me not as a window by
helping me look back at the things I do
to understand myself better and whether
it's data that I put out there in the
course of doing other things like flickr
and facebook or whether it's wearing
special purpose capture tools like the
sense cam that was developed at
microsoft by gordon bell and others that
takes a picture every 30 seconds you
know everywhere you go or whether it's
something like Fitbit that sort of
tracks you know when you're being
physically active and then you can
upload that and think about you know the
times of day and the places where you do
things right these data can help us not
just sort of model people right or build
systems that take advantage of this
knowledge to make recommendations or
sell ads but to help us understand
ourselves and so so that's what most of
this talk is going to be about and in
particular it's going to be about a very
specific kind of self-understanding
that's a big problem for me personally
which is reminiscing and reflecting on
the past and in fact if you look at a
lot of people's research you'll find
that the problems that they work on
actually are things that affect them or
the people around them and that's
actually a really cool thing right
because then you're really motivated to
work on it and so I'm going to be
talking about reminiscing and the system
called pensive which is in fact related
to the harry potter pensieve artifact in
ways that will become apparent soon and
we'll talk about this as a case of
helping people understand themselves
right we'll talk about some of the
forces that shape the data that these
systems can use and we'll talk a little
bit about design ideas for sort of
managing those forces social forces
forces you know about impression
management forces about the face that we
put on for others forces about you know
our relationships that sort of make
things more or less interesting or
appropriate or comfortable to talk about
online right and then maybe if we have
time at the end we'll talk a little bit
about you know more
targeted applications that try to make
people healthier and happier physically
and mentally alright so that's the goal
other thing about this talk if you have
questions at any time feel free to throw
them in there will be a explicit pause
for questions in about 15 18 minutes
when we first finished talking about
pensive but if you have questions along
the way just throw them out there okay
alright so why reminiscing why did I
care about this so much so I my ex-wife
made a lot of fun of me during the 17
years because I just didn't remember
things at all I didn't remember the past
right and I especially didn't remember
good things about the past I seem to
have a talent for remembering
embarrassing moments but many of the
good things that happened to me just
sort of slip away right and I almost
never take time to think about them by
myself either the good ones or the bad
ones because you know people are busy
and you've got other things in your life
but it turns out that this reminiscing
is actually really important right
people in psychology have studied
reminiscing it plays huge valuable
functions in terms of things like
helping you sort of manage today's
problems by sort of applying lessons
from your past right it helps you come
to grips with the person you were before
who is not necessarily a very good
person right bad things happen to you
you do bad things and reminiscing is one
of the ways that we sort of manage and
come to understand these things about
ourselves reminiscing is a social
activity for a lot of people I'm telling
stories about my life and my past in
part to help make social connections and
get you interested in this talk we
reminisce with people to make
friendships and we remember we reminisce
about people when they're not around
right either because they're physically
distant or they die or other other
reasons that people sort of fall out of
our lives right this is actually
something that although you think about
old people on a park bench right in fact
everybody reminisce is all the time all
right now if I asked you right now what
was the last time you reminisced and it
you might actually have trouble pulling
that out of your brain right because we
did this in our first set
interview studies when we're trying to
really understand what's going on with
people remembering the past and and and
you know people actually stop I don't
know right but in fact you know it's
kind of triggered all the time by a
story by a smell by some piece of
context that you see and if you you know
probably after this talk as you're going
through the rest of your day you'll note
it will be more likely to notice it
right so take a minute to kind of notice
the role that is playing in your life um
for me like I said in general I didn't
spend much time remembering the past and
because sue that ex-wife made fun of me
I started keeping a diary of all the
things that happened to me right is back
in like 98 is when I started it and so
here as you can see it's kind of kind of
some of the bad things right i mean this
guy who had a big fight with my sister
thrusting her diploma in my face at her
graduation now it turns out right at the
time i was just angry but turns out that
my sisters three years younger than me
and so in school right she always got
the oh or you're Danny's sister thing
right that siblings often get when a
older sibling comes through right
because I was the smart kid and so
people were like oh you're Danny's
sister right and she always could was
kind of annoyed by that and the fact
that she was behind but she actually got
her master's degree before I did write
her life kind of took her straight to
that and so she was really proud and so
so thinking about this right at the time
was just angry right but but but
thinking about this now really kind of
helps me understand better this
relationship right now the weird thing
is that if it weren't for this talk
right now I probably would not have
looked at that right because like every
other piece of social media the old
stuff goes away and in fact I never read
this thing myself right i read it
exactly once a year when i took the file
name and i changed it to diary 1998 and
queered it out so I could start 1999
right and so I almost never looked at
these data and if you think about your
own data in social media you know you
probably have non-trivial amounts of
Flickr you have bunch of photos or even
on your phone you probably have a bunch
of photos and my guess
is you don't flip through them all that
often right but they're there they're
waiting for you and my insight was that
well we do have all this stuff and
further the computers could read it for
us right that it could the computer
could sort of take the stuff aggregated
process at parse it and then because
reminiscing is usually spontaneous what
I told my computer to do was start
sending me text messages with little
snippets of my past from years ago right
so you know I was um I would you know I
started doing that I did the prototype
for this system in like two thousand
eight um and and and and you so I was
getting stuff from three five ten years
ago right the very first message it sent
me was the thing I wrote on sep tember
11 2001 right so not all of these memory
pieces that it sends our good right that
was bad this one is not very good either
this was me at the end of an internship
right oh wow this internship was
actually a really cool opportunity but
by the end of it i'm sitting in this
restaurant in the middle of nowhere new
jersey like god i just want to go home
right you know you had this kind of
fatigue and thinking about what an
internship was a but so anyway so so so
the you know the reminiscing right it
would spark me four or five times a day
to think about these elements of myself
that otherwise I might have sort of lost
and I showed this to people and they
said well that's pretty interesting we
have this stuff too and I got a team of
undergrads at Cornell interest in the
project and they um they they said let's
design a system that other people can
use that doesn't just work with your
blog right and so the big design
question right up front was what should
the system be like right and and and
we're not the first people to talk about
reminiscing and HCI this this guy on the
left is called the FM radio the family
memories radio right and what it would
do is it would record they took an old
radio and repurposed it's a record
sounds that happened around the house
and then invited people to experience
those sounds later sound being a pretty
powerful trigger for reminiscing right
you hear that song that you and your
boyfriend
chance to at the prom and you know it's
our song and it brings back lots of
memories and so that was this in this
that's cool right or this guy here is
called the living memory box it was
developed at Georgia Tech back in 2003
and the idea was that you would put some
tchotchke that you got on your trip to
Paris all right arm into there and it
would scan it and then you would record
a little bit of video about it right so
that there was some context so that when
you croaked your kids would find this
Eiffel Tower statue and they'd be like
one is what meaning does that happen
they put it in the box and be like oh
yeah Paris that's where we had Bobby
right and so you'd find out something
that you might know how to think about
about your parents exactly but the idea
was that you know you could attach
context to physical objects right that
would then make them sort of more
memorable and useful for other people
later and these are cool right these are
cool systems but there's systems that
are like special purpose all right you
have to if you're gonna go play with the
digital memory box your ruler the living
memory box you really have to go use
this tool right and and and and and some
are gonna sting is actually very special
in this way right the photo album right
grandpa pulls out the photo album and
shows it to kids right or grandpa pulls
out you know the eight right you know
the 35 millimeter projector and shows
some home videos of his grandpa from
1942 right as kind of and sometimes
these tools are appropriate but because
of reminiscing is importance because of
the fact that it's often spontaneous
because it's something that we just sort
of do as part of our art our gig of
being human um well we were inspired by
was this idea of everyday computing that
came out of Georgia Tech the idea that
there are certain things that we want to
do they're not tasks that we're trying
to finish right there are things that
are woven throughout our lives right
like monitoring the awareness of your
friends on Facebook that's not a task
that's everyday computing right and we
saw reminiscing in this way and so our
designs had to fit existing practices
and uses they had to be things that
people do in context they already do
them right because if you ask people to
do something new hey design you use this
new crazy tool that you've never
used before chances are it's not going
to work very well because why should
they bother learning why should they
invest the time right we wanted to use
existing media and content for the same
reason a it reduces cost be it has stuff
that is actually useful for the task of
reminiscing right because not all though
not everything you put on Twitter is
meaningful a lot of it is right more so
than like the average picture that the
sense cam would take right you're
actually being selective about what what
is important to you when you put it into
social media um the undergrads I was
working with really hated the text
messages for exactly the reasons that I
love them and the reason they hated it
was because apparently young people this
pains me to say this because this means
I'm old people but but you know if they
get a notification on their phone find
it very hard not to look at their phone
and play with their phone and text
someone on their phone right this is
happening in the audience even as we
speak and and and which is cool right
but they didn't want to be forced to
reminisce and they talked about
situations like suppose I'm in a job
interview and one of these things comes
up right and I see something about my
dead dog fluffy and I cried during the
job interview actually think that would
increase your chances of getting the job
interview well maybe not pulling out
your phone in the middle of it and an
interview but but but but they wanted
more control right but we still wanted
it to be something that people would
just engage with as part of their their
their day-to-day life and at
unpredictable times and then finally
everybody we interviewed said man I wish
I had more of this stuff to think about
and reflect on and so the design our
goal is to try and encourage people once
they started reminiscing to make it
really easy for them to sort of record
thoughts or reflections or other things
that they might want to reminisce on
later and so we went through some
prototypes we did some iterating even
the name was up in the air for a while
some people liked pensieve some people
liked flashback right and flashbacks a
little weird because it's got that LSD
connotation and it also makes me think
of like back to the future but and
eventually pensive one and it turns out
the pensive right I mean you guys are
actually going to laugh when you see
pensive um pensive the
go artifact is not hard hence of the
technological artifact is something that
any senior could build be no this
because a bunch of seniors built it
right it's a website that you sign in to
create an account and then tell it about
social media where you have information
that might be useful for you to
reminisce about not any social medium we
didn't want to store passwords OAuth
wasn't as popular at this time so we
want to picking only public things right
Flickr Picasa blogger Twitter last.fm
last.fm because it's got these sounds
and sounds are actually pretty
interesting for reminiscing about right
and also these were the systems that the
undergrads who were working on the
project had a lot of their data in right
so it was very sort of self centered
self driven research right oh and so you
would go to pensive and for many people
this was the last time they would ever
see the website right you could go back
to the website for other things you
could control how often you got the
triggers by default we sent them once a
day you could make it multiple times a
day you could do it like once a week
right so you could sort of tune it to
your level of desire need for
reminiscing but mostly the way people
interacted three male this is the
compromise the spontaneity control
compromise is three male so what pensive
would do is it would wake up every once
in a while as a cron job on some web
hosting service and it would go through
everybody and say hey is it time for a
memory trigger and if it was it would
randomly pick one of the services that
you would put in there or one special
service oops one special service that we
put in is not everybody uses social
media for these things and so we also
created some of these non-personalized
prompts right prompts that were derived
from this idea called reminiscence
therapy from the literature we're in
care homes like a caregiver would have a
conversation with a group of residents
and say hey think about this moment in
your lives and this is not data that's
specific to you but most of you can
probably think of the best concert that
you ever went to or you know like me I
have never been to a concert right so
for me that this was actually not very
useful but you know for many of these
prongs right remember learning to cook
ah
remember a fall day where you grew up
right what was your favorite pair of
sunglasses right things that that
although not necessarily tuned to you
could be pretty evocative for things
that had happened in your life um it
would also you know so I i mostly got
these uh this guy here is John Baxter
he's actually one of the lead develop
undergrad developers on the project
living out his Star Wars fantasies on on
on picasa right he's not quite Star Wars
kid in this picture but close and um and
and and and you would get these emails
and you had no particular task right
yeah reminisce or don't think about it
or not doing now or later right because
our goal wasn't to try to structure
people's reminiscing or change it it was
just to make it sort of salient in their
lives a little more than an otherwise
would be on the one other feature the
pensive did have was a diary right so we
conceived of this not as a social
reminiscing tool right which most HCI
research focuses on helping people
reminisce together supporting families
but as an individual reminiscing tool
right aimed at helping you sort of think
about yourself and so this diary
metaphor becomes really appropriate for
that is where I write my private
thoughts about these data that I put
into social media right because as well
see you know in social media you have
this kind of positivity bias here's a
space where you could tell you know the
backstory that you're not willing to put
on stage in front of other folks um and
the really sort of one really awesome
thing about this is that one of the
other we developers on the project brian
olson was like boy wouldn't it be cool
right if you really believe in this idea
of embedding this in people's daily
activities maybe people should be able
to write diary entries by just replying
to the email right now if you're like a
designer trying to drive traffic to your
site you're like god what an awful
decision right because that means
they'll never visit your site but in
fact by putting it right at the moment
when they were reminiscing about the
data that they were sent and by making
it unbelievably easy to write diary
entries that way that's how we got
almost
all of the responses that we got from
pensive right there are a few people who
would go to their diary once every few
weeks and go through a whole bunch of
things and write but most of the
responses were because we sort of really
integrated it into the process we didn't
make it special we made it normal right
that's what we were designing for and so
we threw this out into the world um we
made it publicly available we spread the
word right so if you look at the
demographics right the female male 1 is
interesting because women on average are
shown to value reminiscing more and so
it kind of makes sense that that's how
it broke down on the age group one you
can guess how that happened right a
younger people have more stuff on social
media be the research team from which
the advertising started were undergrads
right and so we tended to have more
younger people although a non-trivial
number of people of old people like
myself who used it um about 11,000
prompts went out most of them were this
non-personal I stuff it turns out that
only some people were interested in and
willing to put their personal content
out there for a system to look at in
part because of privacy concerns in part
because they weren't sure what we would
do with the data right but you know on
balance people wound up using it a fair
amount most people didn't turn it off
didn't unsubscribe there was a
reasonable number of diary entries right
about one in 15 prompts got a diary
entry right which is actually a
non-trivial response rate for random
emails to come all the time and um and
then we also so we analyzed this stuff
we analyze the behavior we analyze some
questionnaire responses that we got to
try to understand what if anything
pensive was doing for or two people hey
Joss and Victoria were the grad students
who were in the weed on the project at
this time and the basic answer is that I
mean it it works so I mean it just
worked right that people got the
triggers if they were ready for them
they reminisced if not they put it off
till a later time sometimes they ignore
them when their life was too busy but on
balance they really said yeah you know I
don't need to write right not everybody
wrote a lot but even the ones who
weren't writing right we're using the
triggers to sort of reflect on
themselves right exactly what we were
aiming for and it's important to think
about this because in the first version
of this paper right in the first version
of the Chi paper we talked about you
know analyzing reminiscing right when we
were really talking about analyzing the
stuff that people row right the
reminiscing was going on in their heads
right not all the important things that
happen in the systems that you build are
the visible things that you can see
right so for instance if you are
building tools for health right suppose
that you're building a tool to help
people eat healthier or reduce smoking
right eventually you don't want them
using your system right you don't want
to someone to have to wear the nicotine
patch for the rest of their lives right
and so thinking about whether you really
need the behavior in your system to show
victory right or whether you can just
ask people oh yes this actually worked
in even though you can't see it it's
actually important and they're right
it's something we tend to forget as
designers right we tend to log and we
tend to rely on the logs because that's
what we can see and what we can
manipulate but a lot of the important
stuff is invisible um further what
happened with the with the with the
system right was not so different from
what really happens in reminiscing
people use it to think about themselves
they used it to maintain social
relationships right we weren't trying to
change the process we weren't trying to
change people's values we weren't trying
to change the goals right we were trying
to just make it a little easier a little
more salient and basically it was it was
total in this sense it was pretty much
total victory right these are broad
sentiments from the people who were
posting things both in the triggers in
the questionnaires it's not perfect
right not everything is meaningful this
one person kept getting a picture they
had like a photo album that just had a
picture of a mushroom on a rock and the
random algorithm that chose which
content to show for some reason picked
this
a lot and they're like wow pencil kind
of sucks it shows me pictures of
mushrooms right and you would like
probably to figure out what's more or
less meaningful to people and try to
send the more meaningful stuff right um
people also talked about this idea that
not everything that comes out of your
past is good and it turns out that
there's a whole sub field of psychology
around or psychotherapy or on cognitive
based therapies that try to get you to
sort of think about you know sort of
train the way that you think about
things and one of the common techniques
they use is taking past events and then
reflecting on in this guy Jamie
Pennebaker at UT Austin throw something
called the expressive writing paradigm
where we just ask people to write about
traumatic incidents in their lives just
right no grading no analysis nothing but
that if you sort of measure before and
afters right in terms of like
psychological scales of well-being
people get better it helps them just to
write about the past right and so even
though pensive did have the potential of
triggering negative memories writer for
instance for me my ex wife shows up in
these things right for some people
that'll be a really negative memory for
me it's not fortunately um but but you
know on balance people said well
although it was sometimes uncomfortable
it was actually sort of important to do
um but it is something to think about
right the sort of unintended or
potential negative consequences of your
crazy designs and then the third thing
that we saw was this idea that culture
matters that um you know we had a bunch
of rich white kids in the Northeast
writing these prompts right and so when
he said something about prom right
people who are from the US or like what
and you know although this is also kind
of design 101 right you should be aware
that not everybody is identical and you
should be sensitive to cultural contexts
you know we got some really powerful
feedback about that right that that the
ways that we sort of trigger this
reminiscing and think about it right
it's important to tune it to different
purposes and we'll talk about this
personalization actually a little bit
later but um you know that
high level bit right is is this idea
that reminiscing is actually something
that's useful um that social media
content is useful trigger for it that um
you know Facebook did this right first
with photo memory then with time hot or
with timeline this company time hop
right that sends you reminders from you
know one year ago today things from your
social media right these are things are
out in the world now or it's something
that people care about the value that
they do and so we'll talk about this a
little bit more but the question started
and this is actually where I normally
pause for questions anyways so let's
have some questions so about two slides
back you said something about measuring
success outside your InDesign system
mm-hmm can you elaborate a little bit of
how you would measure that because
self-report is notoriously in unreliable
when it comes free so this long day that
it turns out yeah but yeah I right you
know no this is the point right no one
data source is telling you everything
right not everything gets logged systems
fail right not all of my personal
behavior gets online I self-censor right
so that's also got some danger in it
right and so thinking about what are the
different ways that you can evaluate
right I mean yes in some crazy perfect
instant buy some definitions world right
I could sort of hook you up the stress
sensors and I can measure your stress
continuously over time right and i can
give you this tool and then i could say
well if you use pensive right your
average stress level is point 26
gigajoules or whatever you're measuring
stress level and um lower than if you
didn't use the system therefore it wins
right but you can't necessarily do that
either right the biggest point though is
that that you know if we spend all and
only our time on sort of behavior right
especially when one of the goals of the
system is to encourage behaviors that
aren't in the system right reminiscing
behavior is not in pensive reminiscing
behavior is here social media data is
not memories it's data that people use
to
remember right and so you really have to
think carefully about what it is you're
trying to accomplish right and what are
the things that you can measure however
imperfectly that get addict right and
whether it scales before and after its
measuring stress or its qualitative
interviews they each tell you some piece
of this story yeah that's convinces in
time scale and how you might design for
practices of reminiscing versus
practices of gratitude somehow example
where people um are trying to practice
gratitude they may be practicing
gratitude in blood that they're in my
mouth on a present moment and also other
Pettis is a gratitude or sample at this
of testing yourself what went well and
then say oh no yesterday this was wrong
yeah so there's a couple of pieces of
that right so one is um when you say
gratitude and thing about the what going
well there's actually this other piece
of cognitive psych all our of psychology
positive psychology right it's a group
of people who said let's not focus on
just you know sort of you know
clinically depressed people let's think
about what people can do to improve
their well-being across the entire
spectrum right and so positive
psychology is the name this goes by and
they actually have done a number of
things in their similar in some ways to
that Pennebaker expressive writing
paradigm that we mentioned earlier they
actually just ask you to think what are
three good things that happen yesterday
and why did they happen right they asked
you to think about you know somebody who
you feel gratitude for from your past
and write a letter to them and deliver
it right and they have this set of
interventions that one might use to AH
you know in a more structured way than
pensive right to you know organize the
reminiscing in ways that have been shown
right if my goal was to improve people's
psychological well-being directly in
ways I can measure and scales and at
ways that positive psychology had
thought about I would have done self you
know I would have done sort of
questionnaires before and after using
sort of validated scales and I would
have been very careful to study that
right my goal was to prompt reminiscing
not necessarily to you know improve
well-being cuz if it wasn't
obvious to me that it would right but
you could totally do that right you
could totally structure this and in fact
victorious Asik the student who we saw
earlier on the slide her dissertation is
positive psychology right with social
media content to support it right to
make it more interesting to make it
lower costs to prompt more memories to
introduce variety all of which the goal
is to get people to do that practice for
a longer time to do three good things
exercises for a month instead of a week
because on balance the research shows
that the longer you do it the more
benefit that you get right and so
structuring it's that it's something
that could happen over time or you know
I goes talking with joy earlier instead
of focusing on one piece of content at a
time figuring out a way to tell a story
across a set of content that you had
what is this archive of data or what is
this album of pictures or what all the
interactions I've had with you say about
our relationship can I think about the
relationship not individual moments in
it right is actually kind of a really
promising extension to this kind of work
hard for reasons we'll talk about it a
little bit I think about promising more
questions
let's talk about some of the hard things
then all right so on Victoria and
another student changzhou started
looking at how people do this kind of
memory work around data that is in
facebook instead of using pensive itself
as a system and focusing on individuals
they wanted to focus on kind of social
processes so they looked at friendships
and romantic relationships and how
people use these data to think about
them the bigger picture of them in the
way that we were just talking about and
it turns out that you know there's
something really weird going on right
that if I show you a picture if I show
you this particular picture of Victoria
and Lindsay and ask you to think about
your relationship it's really easy to
think about that event and it's really
hard to think about the relationship
because the data by bringing in all
these associations in your head about
that particular moment in your
relationship get you to think about this
thing that happened right and it turns
out that people right we learn patterns
rise crazy neural networks up in our
head sort of lead to kind of patterns
and general understandings but the way
we tend to experience memories fred is
through these kind of individual moments
right in fact if I tell you remember
some time span right that's I don't even
know if we can do that why right we can
remember pieces of it and then we can
tell ourselves stories about those
pieces but in fact it's really hard to
get people to think like scientists
about themselves right people are not
trained to be scientists they're not
trained to interpret graphs right so you
see a lot of quantified self hey if you
just track all the food that you eat and
then show you a big graph of your food
eating over time you'll be a better food
eater well maybe but people are not so
good at that right we actually had some
other students a couple of undergrads oj
and tiffany built the system called pi
time where they collected people's phone
records and their gmail archives and
then they sort of segmented it out kind
of like that graph we saw earlier by
hour of the day by day of the week by
month of the year
right because these cyclical patterns
actually do matter and they were hoping
to get people to think about these
patterns in their lives right so this is
someone's email archive over the week
here's Sunday here's Friday turns out
Friday less email right everybody's off
partying and doing things that aren't
work um and so you can get some really
coarse insights to it but but what they
really thought was that it was going to
help people see these big structures and
how their lives were organized and it
turns out that these are you know
despite this very nice idea of a pie as
kind of a unifying circular thing in the
circle of life and circles of time and
cano ting clocks and all the cool visual
design justifications they had for this
idea people actually couldn't use it
until they noticed that there were some
details associated with each of the time
slices right people would sit and stare
this and then they would see up top
right for this slice the sort of
maximally improbable words compared to
the rest of the corpus right so we're
doing kind of the Amazon game the tf-idf
game the the naive based spam filter
game and they picked out the words that
were most characteristic of this time
region and then people like oh okay
what's going on is that on in November
my mom was sick right and so they
started thinking about why they had
these patterns but again in terms of
these specific individual incidents
right the ways that memories get
triggered in her head associatively one
memory at a time and so you know putting
that together and helping people see
these patterns it was actually a
non-trivial challenge for reflection
people also didn't put lunch in their
news feeds right some people do there
been studies some folks at Rutgers did
this a few years ago they this semi
famous paper about me formers versus
informers people who talk about
themselves in social media versus
sharing ah you know sort of useful
general purpose information but in fact
most people don't put everything in
their streams partly because some of it
is so mundane it's not worth noting
imagine a facebook friend who posted 29
times a day I actually wrote a piece of
software once that let other people set
my facebook status right because I
thought it would be really interesting
to see what the social
implications of that were right what
would people do if they were able to set
my facebook status well I demoed this in
a class and everybody started setting my
status you know saying danco is going to
give me a good grade and things like
that and and which was cool but it
turned out that this is like the day
after Facebook changed the way it
represented its newsfeed right at one
point would only show one post by a
particular friend like the day after I
threw this into the world they changed
their news feeds that showed everything
that you did if you weren't careful and
so I like inundated my friends news
feeds with all these posts from other
people right and so most people don't
put everything up there and further even
if they wanted to social norms right I
get to say some non normal things or I
get to talk about some negative things
because i'm talking about reminiscing
and you know sometimes reminiscing is
difficult and painful and so talking
about ex-wives and people buying and
things like that normally you wouldn't
hear that in a talk right and normally
on facebook you wouldn't be posting bad
things or if you look at the language of
social media right if you run it through
kind of that same sentiment analysis
tool that these colleagues of mine were
using earlier you'll find that the words
that people use in social media our way
happier than average so much so that you
know their people have studied on how
reading other people's newsfeeds makes
us feel inadequate and jealous right
because it looks like everybody's shiny
happy successful people because they're
filtering the negative and emphasizing
the positive friend and so if you wanted
to build a system that helped people do
sort of Pennebaker style stuff that
would pull out these difficult moments
it would be harder because there's this
positivity bias right and this
positivity buyers right these biases all
right don't just affect sort of
reminiscing right they offend this goes
back to the what can you learn from log
data right the self self reports or
logged it you know when it with that
that world happiness on Twitter graph
right I put quotes around every single
word world because not everybody uses it
happiness because it's like this weird
definition that involves using words
that have positive and negative emotions
and then Twitter right because a it was
only a relatively small slice of sweet
Twitter even though 500 500 million
tweets are that's a lot of tweets still
just a slice very
short time period right happiness might
change in six months those tweets might
have been about your during a
particularly happy a particularly sad
season right and so the data we see has
these biases embedded in it um and it
has them for lots of reasons right in
part because we have presentational
concerns right goffman talks about the
front stage in the back stage right
there are things you're willing to
express in front of other people and
there are parts of yourself that you're
not usually willing to express all right
that's part of what drives us positivity
bias the relationships that were in can
affect the things that that we decide to
disclose right I may want to talk about
a relationship my partner might not I
might want to make it widely publicized
other people might want to make it
private mine or might be to sort of you
know emphasized I'm in a relationship by
posting lots of pictures of me and my
sweetie Ryan both to say wow smart nerdy
kid finally got in a relationship and
also right and this was actually an
explicit strategy people talked about
and how they use Facebook they would tag
themselves with their romantic partners
as kind of an ownership claim on that
partner to tell the rest of the world
back off ladies he's mine right and and
and the end these things really do shape
sort of the world that we see online and
so does the fact that um although you
know at different times and this is
actually worth it Neil far was played a
major role in I will she was a Cornell
last summer um this idea right that we
have this stage metaphor that we're sort
of filtering in the moment to decide
what's appropriate and inappropriate
well once we've done this filtering
write the data starts fading into the
past and suddenly instead of a stage
right which is gafas metaphor Bernie
Hogan talks about it as an exhibition
where the system controls the picture of
who you are right on Facebook your your
past is timeline and you have very
little control over how your past is
represented on Facebook right in
principle you can change privacy
settings
people don't in principle you can do eet
things again most people don't because
you know one other thing about social
media is that it's not just for social
it's also for self right that Facebook
is actually a stage and it's a museum
and it's a personal kind of archive
right you know people told a lot of
stories when they were doing this about
yeah that picture where my hair looks
bad but I'm with his friend so I don't
want it to be shown on facebook but I do
want to have it for later because I
remember the friend right in a in a
world of sort of radical transparency
and system control right it becomes a
lot harder to think about well how how
can I make a space for myself inside a
social media or inside of Facebook and
so there's all these pressures right
there's pressures about what data can do
about what data is appropriate to put
there and about what people want to do
with the data now and later and what it
means make this kind of a challenging
problem right that whatever we see about
ourselves online whether it's systems or
researchers or us ourselves is this kind
of imperfect reflection of who we are
right so that's most of the talk and so
I'm going to take another pause for
questions
it's always really awkward as a teacher
I have been in pause for questions 30
seconds feels like forever in a context
like this it does if you ever wind up
student teaching or running a section or
something right be careful because
you'll like asked does anybody have any
questions and you like two seconds
you're like no okay good and then you'll
move on right and then there will be all
these questions that you never get to
answer yes so I was just certain thing
about light the so Facebook is this
control system and so if I want to have
some system or light not going back to
like reminiscing for personal uses maybe
this book isn't the right things um but
and I'm just trying to think about how
to phrase this because Facebook plays a
really big role in a sense that like
everybody's on there that's getting
would be less true as teenagers decided
it's not the cool thing anymore but like
it's certainly for my generation right
it's going to be everybody's on there so
they bring everything together in a way
that some personal tool would do that
yeah so I'm just like like it's just a
hard balance maybe to like try to
balance that like bring people together
to get that kind of social stuff but
also yeah well there was surly you know
it's kind of like the convergence versus
divergence argument for a while people
thought maybe we'd carry around lots of
special-purpose gadgets until
smartphones came out and then
smartphones were good enough at
everything that we want to do they were
good enough cameras they were good
enough phones are good enough email
devices right um we actually had this
with pensive we tried to build a social
version of it right we try to embed
social features where people could share
things that they had gotten to reminisce
with their friends about and it was a
total spectacular brutal failure right
for partly because pensive had been
established as for individuals right the
diary metaphor doesn't work if you're so
you know nobody has group Diaries think
about how weird that would be um but
also because like you said the action is
in facebook and right so one of the
answers are as figuring out where to
make spaces for these different needs
and whether it's within the platform in
pieces right could you have a facebook
application that's set on the sign of it
that would you know you can move things
to and from you know shens idea was this
idea that you have a drawer right where
you can put content I mean you
handset they one of the problems with
the Facebook design right is that you
can set things private but there's no
way to easily look at my private stuff
right and so but you could imagine doing
a little more thoughtful design around
Facebook that made it you know here's
the damn coat part of face someone
actually has a hack for this in Google+
right or you make a circle and then you
don't add anyone to it and you share
stuff of that circle and now you have a
private archive Ryan but you know
thinking sort of intentionally about
these needs and how our systems do or
don't I think that's one of the big
design questions around it yeah I think
one of the problems with the making
things personal unlike timeline or
Google+ is that a lot of the content
that has meaning says is not owned by us
so like it's a graduation picture
someone of your friends took it and put
it online and it might be really
personal to you but if that person the
x-rays they're faced with you just
losing it right we'll hold them as a
researcher at Carnegie Mellon who's also
interested in this general space of
things he's got this idea called virtual
possessions right the idea that we have
this digital content as meaning to us
but that it's in the cloud that often
other people can't roll it right that
this makes things even more complicated
for thinking about how we manage these
archives right and you know whether the
answer is copies or replication or
rights you know I imagine your UNIX file
system right where you can have multiple
links to the same file and you can
delete your link in the files still
there for me write whether there's some
notion of multiple ownership that's like
the right way to handle you know online
data it's unclear right but it is true
right a lot of the things that that are
special to us right are things that
other people create and attach us to
write photos with me and you together
that someone else has right and it's
actually really are people talked about
this in the paper where you would get in
one of the ways they dealt with this bad
hair picture problem is that you know
someone would tag you in the picture and
you wouldn't approve it but you wouldn't
deny it either you would just leave it
in limbo right so that you would see it
and this is actually one of the places i
think in facebook right is this place
for things that need approve
rides that's actually it also has this
nice side effect of carving out a
private space to look at these things
that you want for you but for nobody
else right or people talked about this
with relationship statuses um in
facebook turns out that if you set the
privacy settings of your relationship
status right you can actually manage
tensions between nerdo boys need to know
that you're willing to put your
relationship out there publicly and your
desire not to sort of spam your friends
with relationship things and so this
this woman actually you know set it set
in a relationship and then made that
visible only to her boyfriend and to try
to negotiate some of these forces right
she was using or like the Google+ hack
or like tagging and putting things into
limbo right right now people want these
things and they sort of force the
interface to do it and this is no
surprise when people appropriate
interfaces in ways that you don't expect
all the time right it's like Twitter was
intended to be what Twitter is today
right Twitter just kind of happened
because people said oh I can do this I
can do this I can do this right but you
might want to think about well can I
design right can I make a space for the
relationship right that is for not me
not you right with all the tensions
around being visible to our different
social networks but this is the space in
renren this is lover space the space for
us right where the content that's about
us goes right so I don't have to think
well if I put it in my feet I'm sending
these certain signals or not sending
these certain signals to my relations my
network I put it in the place for us is
not my profile on printer I don't speak
Chinese I don't use the system nor is it
stand in Wendy's profile that's just
Shenzhou Shen Shen and her talk for this
use them as sort of indicators the
typical two people in a relationship but
but this idea that you might design a
place a space for private for
relationships a space to you know make
meaning not just over one piece of
content but over many of them right a
space to tell a story about
out a time in your life a particular
visit a particular relationship right
and then put things together that that
make these bigger meanings right it's
kind of an interesting design question
another one is to match up patterns in
particulars right so ben shneiderman
write a visualization information
visualization fame has this idea that
you should be able to when you show
people big amounts of data both look at
overviews big picture patterns and then
zoom in on details right and it just
causes overview and zoom and in fact one
thing to think about so this picture
over here is activity data organized by
day of week and time of day right this
picture says something about this person
right they exercise a couple of nights a
week they have some longer period of
exercise it's very regular on Sundays
all right so it's why they exercise in
the morning and so this is this is one
way of saying Who I am as an exerciser
right but there's another way to say it
which is to take the specific individual
moments right the triathlons the races
that you ran and so hooking up you know
a lot of the work we do in computer
science right we tend to think about
graphs and aggregation and learning and
sort of presenting people with
conclusions that the systems designers
or the system's themselves come up with
pairing those interpretations up with
the details that go in behind them so
that people can do this kind of meaning
making process probably a big win for
thinking about helping people understand
themselves right so if you're developing
a persuasive computing technology if
you're developing a you know healthy
eating technology right if you're
developing something to encourage people
to sleep more or an appropriate amount
right showing them not just the patterns
not just a raw dump of the data but some
some representation that really helps
them go back and forth between these
things is probably going to be the win
um especially a win if you can sort of
capture importa moments of context one
of the reasons timehop was so clever was
that was like oh one year ago today all
right because the time of year is
actually a kind of a salient memory cue
for people so
or the people you were around so are the
things that you're talking about so is
the place that you did something right
place is a pretty powerful trigger we
prototyped in google maps right hey make
a make a memory map of your life right
and people found these places they use
them in a lot of different ways but they
found this idea of place pretty
compelling right and you could totally
imagine a system that encouraged you you
know going back to this everyday
computing instead of sitting down in
front of a computer and using google
maps to record your memories you'd be
walking around campus you'd be walking
by your house and you would hear a story
right that would be like a story about a
student from five years ago right or
someone who used to live in your house
right your phone would that be running
this app the stories the memories that
people have left might become visible to
you you might then internally some
stories for the people that come behind
you right so reminiscing and memory not
just for individuals but for groups or
for cultures right using context as a
way to do that right time hops mobile
now it shouldn't just look at one year
ago today it should try to be smarter um
we talked about spaces for self so so
I'm actually going to wrap it up here
because people seem a little energy
today and another it's like midterms
thing or I'm boring today or what but
but but this is this idea all right this
general idea that there's a lot out
there about who we are Ryan and that as
designers right we have lots of options
of things to do with these data right we
can build models we can build
recommender systems we can build graphs
we can build papers we can build
theories right but we can also sort of
think about the things that we could
build to help people more directly think
about themselves or even to work
together so at the HCI wants to is
talking about why voice interfaces for
like Google glass don't work that well
is his theory was that um you know
there's a lot of the time you know
there's no good way to sort of resolve
ambiguities and ground the conversation
so the example was i said i want to go
to alabama street it doesn't understand
it shows you a map of alabama
right no human being would do that but a
human being might not realize that you
wanted alabama street either right but
instead of making the sort of
statistically most likely gasps right
what they would say is like what do you
mean right and then there'd be this
little conversation between the system
and the person to sort of resolve these
meetings right we tend to think well if
we can just model it and solve the
problem right if we can just get the one
true perfect relevant search results
where we don't have to ask the person
anything to get the answer right but i
think these worlds where we actually
sort of yolk people and systems together
to sort of solve the problem together
here the machine gives some suggestions
the person says no i don't like this
this i do like next time around the
system gives other suggestions for
content to reflect on or exercises to do
or meals to eat right these kind of
designs that put sort of systems and
researchers and people themselves
together to make the meanings out of the
data i actually think that's kind of
where the big win is gonna be right and
we all tend to see just a piece of the
puzzle because we only learn and are
good at certain things right but the
places where they come together really
cool places so so that's where I'll stop
and I'll take any more questions and
yeah sure so one of the things that this
last section you're talking about me and
you think of in terms of like the
conversations i really enjoy the NPR
story for which is where they drive a
van around to various places around the
u.s. and they have people come in as
duo's or trio where one family member
will interview another family member so
that you're getting this kind of
personal interaction between two very
close people but then you're recording
it uh-huh and that kind of becomes a
story though that people can participate
like oh this is a story from Alabama or
this is a story from California you're
interviewing your grandmother about 50s
or whatever it was um and so it seems
like that's a movie there's a personal
connection
which makes that reminiscing really nice
which he maybe don't get when you're
just emailing the computer and the
computer can't necessarily create that
meaningful conversation to you in a way
that it could mean to people it's almost
like for me like what I was kind of
thinking about there is like you know
yeah the system wants to get this
reminiscing to help you think about in
the future but it leverages real people
and real social context that kind of
bringing a story of yeah and you know
I'm a little bit of a weird on how I
reminisce right I really am kind of a
solitary not very social person by
nature and so I tend to think of
reminiscing is a very sort of individual
thing that goes on in my head I know
this isn't true for most people and this
is this was actually one of the
interesting things from that see
friendship study right that we actually
asked people some people we didn't give
him any Facebook data to look at we
didn't let him see there see friendship
page we just hadn't talked with her
friend right it turns out that the kind
of the same thing happened right just
the same way that data kind of focused
and limited the way that you would
reminisce so would talking with the
other person right it would become just
the stories right it would be
storytelling which is a certain kind of
and value of reminiscing but you know if
the again if the goal is to sort of
reflect on the bigger pattern it doesn't
work so much right so so different
structures for it right I think thinking
about what you're trying to get at and
what you get out of having the
conversation is it that its interactive
it's is it that it prompts pieces of
memory to that that wouldn't have
otherwise come up at San Diego yesterday
I was talking with someone who's doing
research around helping parents of ADHD
kids right there's there's things you
can do to help your kid out right when
they sort of go through episodes or I
don't know this very well so I'm
relaying right here right but basically
they train parents to sort of do
behavioral interventions the problem
right is that when your kids going off
the rails a little bit it's really easy
to get flustered and frustrated yourself
and forget what the intervention is or
that you need to apply it or to have the
level of control right to be able to
apply it in that
so this was the research group right the
idea is well let's let's stress monitor
parents let's try to build models of
stress levels that let us predict when
one of these peaks are going to come up
and then let's send reminders about
these strategies and the needs to apply
them right so this is really cool except
the system usually got it too late right
the system usually couldn't model and
this is something else we do in computer
science all the time we we predict
elections on twitter by modeling using
all the data available to us whether you
know some features that we can measure
right from that particular election turn
out to be predictive of whether someone
one right and this model is totally
useless the next election because you
used all the data right and even if you
were more careful about it you don't
really want to predict the data from
everything you want to predict like
using the first five percent of your
data right hey what's going to happen is
this person going to be a valuable
member of this community is this parent
going to be stressed out is this
innovation going to spread through the
network by looking early on right and so
one thing and the reason why I bring
this up with your question is because
really there's actually an early warning
sign here to write the place where these
people probably should put away some of
their sensors right if it's a parent in
a kid and if a parent gets stressed out
because of their kids behavior right at
least some of the sensing and modeling
should be on the kid right because the
kid starts having this stress and starts
exhibit anees systems before right and
so if you really think about you know
building the system this inter at night
exactly the same kind of interaction but
the idea that there's this other
important element to it that you could
sort of build in from the social
interactions right if you sort of notice
the things that we're going on around me
right if you notice that other people
around me we're starting to get too busy
and not getting enough sleep ride maybe
you could warn me before I got to you
know all nighter mission critical total
a you know stressed out mode right as
soon as you start seeing it by the
people around me by my kids by your
parents and then leveraging these other
signals that people give you to go after
your your problems right so so you
decided stressing not directly related
reminiscence but this idea of thinking
about well what can the social
interaction actually give you right
people do this in health applications to
the right well we got the social
application we got this application for
like behavior support or goal tracking
or losing weight let's add some social
stuff so people can talk and I'll just
magically work better right well maybe
right but if you sort of really think a
little carefully about how you structure
that social interaction I think you're
going to get get sort of better results
right why is it that being able to look
at somebody else's strategies for eating
or weight loss why is that going to help
you right there was a story so there's a
system by Andrea Grymes integrins Parker
a couple years ago from Georgia Tech
where she was looking at trying to get
low income african-americans in Atlanta
to eat better right and Janet a social
element there and the social element was
storytelling about food through cell
phones which were kind of a dominant
platform but voice because you know
people in the community actually valued
the oral communication style more than
like if you can look these things up in
a database and so by sort of leveraging
that social community so this I know
this is an incredibly long winded answer
but this idea of really thinking about
you know what it is social or that this
the interactions that you're trying to
capture are going to do for your goals
right that's kind of that's kind of the
story i would tell when I was thinking
should I have conversations or should it
be a group or should it be an individual
should be a lot of content or a little
how much contact should I use yeah um I
just curious if you have any thoughts I
don't want to just go down the
stereotypical privacy go over the
essence question but I mean you have
these things are drafting
the existing systems like Facebook or
email and this big difference between
say email as federated system versus
Facebook being centralized and very
personal data just mind if you haven't
got about how to so I might mediate a
structure that in a way which I need you
know structure one bit less weirded out
or weeks to lessen like a lot of these
problems comes because you just pile up
data together without any restrictions
on it if book don't understand the
sharing into the system the emotions of
that are yes okay so I've got several
thoughts about this one is the Helena
symbol as a person really articulated
this well right that this idea that
privacy and data right the real problems
happen when data moves into a context
that you didn't expect right it's all
cool if you know that you've told
pensive that faces that you can look at
the facebook data right it's all cool if
you know you understand the privacy
settings on facebook and what the
implications are for right most people
don't though right and so when you find
out that a friend of a friend can look
at your stuff if a friend comments on it
right it becomes very confusing and
awkward to you right because that's not
what you expect so part of the answer
right is is helping people better
understand the implications right making
it more salient right whether it's
making privacy controls more salient or
I saw this really cool poster a few
years ago or someone analyzed company
privacy policies and then look to
whether the interfaces actually had
features for helping you enact to them
right turns out usually not so much but
kind of a really interesting thing to
think about but it also write my you
know the privacy stuff or the
sensitivity stuff I'm working with
someone who's really interested in how
and why people disclose information and
broadcast media like status updates in
facebook right sometimes people do this
in a not very self-aware way right and
sometimes they become aware of it later
right and then they regret it right
that's a line of work that's being done
largely a Carnegie Mellon
right now about regrets in social media
that's kind of interesting why they
happen how do they repair them and
things like this but you know interfaces
could do a job of helping people
understand hmm I'm disclosing something
very personal right now are you sure
that you want to put this out there
right now right give you a tool you know
maybe compare it to your past behavior
to your friends behavior maybe you could
set up you know sort of warnings to
yourself right so maybe instead the
computer making decisions about you'd
say hey anything that looks you know
that like I'm above stress level you
know over 9000 or whatever you need to
tell me you know wait right wait for a
little while or maybe the system can
make really salient audience right so
Michael Bernstein here right did some
work with with this peeps at Facebook
about how people are not really very
good at estimating who their audiences
are in social media and in fact the i
don't know if he's given this talk here
but it turns out people are usually two
to four times under how many people are
likely to see any particular facebook
post right and so helping people see oh
look this data right now is going to go
to many more people than you think and
here's who they probably are right
because you could probably
reverse-engineer a lot of the facebook
newsfeed if you really wanted to um and
then when you think oh that or you know
will be really cool right is sort of
showing the future right what is the
future of your data look like and the
first place I saw this context was like
trying to protect yourself against
making commitments in the future that
you would later regret right we all as
academic said this way of saying oh yeah
I'll go do this talk all be on this
program committee and the interface you
know my calendar interface my to do
interface doesn't sort of show me that
in the future I'll be flying into San
Francisco 1142 and nighttime waiting for
the shuttle ride on and so and and and
and you know I would have come here
anyways but it would have been cool for
the interface to sort of made the
consequences more saline and I think
that's a big picture on the personal
side right so giving me more on
standing and control of what's going on
to the date all right and there's kind
of sort of a legal moral social side
that people like Victor Meyer CERN
burgers talk more about this idea that
data should go away because you know it
presents a past version of us and it
doesn't really represent who we are that
is going to affect us in negative ways
down the road but I know that's kind of
that's kind of what I think about this
right helping people better understand
the implications and giving them the
tools for thinking about it and then
sort of thinking a kind of the legal
social ramming the problem with this is
that anything that that's like this you
suddenly have digital rights management
and it's probably not going to work much
better for individuals than it has
worked for companies which is only but
so good yeah so I example that you
showed me it could be interesting but
it's all things that it's a special case
for anybody to write and we've got this
sort of general is how do you burn a
social experience for n equal to 1 try
to play another Facebook significance
yeah solution in creation ok ok so you
ask two things one is about different
media and one is about different group
sizes just now sighs okay so how how do
you think we could talk with the theory
for any put whatever number I well I
mean unfortunately I think this is
actually going to be just brutally hard
right if you think about I mean this in
some ways you know if you if you want to
go technical side or I think about the
problem of maintaining a group memory
and also who has you know going back to
this question who is the rights to look
at that memory right is essentially it's
pretty similar the problem of access
control lists in you know security right
this question of managing who can and
can and should and shouldn't see the
data is like that's one problem with the
group I actually think though that this
idea of um yeah I think I think you're
right that that you know one of the
things about N equals 2 is that the
negotiations right the number of
stakeholders and who gets to put the
data out there is small right who gets
to say what the official history of my
sorority or the HCI 7
are the synchronized skating club is
right you do want to have these or or of
you know gosh let's let's scale it up a
little bit right it's got Marie small
Venna you know what's the official who
gets to really put the things in and
control the archive of stories from
Irish people talking about the troubles
in Ireland right or what's the official
story of you know the the Somali moved
to Minneapolis writer the Hmong
community in California right who who
gets to say those things that's a hard
question i mean i think this kind of
this aspect of sort of reminiscing and
memory for for large groups and cultures
is actually really fun it's not where I
go because that's not how I'm wired
right but people like Phoebe singers
people like Sophie oh wow right there
thinking you know sort of hard about the
N equals larger problem i think the
practical thing is that some people
become representatives write that in
practice some people write the history
books in families right there's one or
two people who are the memory keepers
right there that person who you know
gathers the tapes makes the scrapbooks
remembers the details and tells the
stories writer in facebook more
prosaically you have a couple people in
your network who are probably willing to
go around and tag everybody in all the
pictures and actually there's a ton of
benefit to that right because a few
people who are willing to do the work
for the community actually benefit a lot
of iran so the question would be how can
you leverage the fact this is kind of a
natural thing to do and you probably
most people don't want to be involved on
a day to day basis with the risks that
you're sort of you run into unresolvable
conflicts like you know the US
government or something so so if this
sends a 2 of 5 officially we're done I
think so let's be done but I'll hang out
here for a little bit for questions and
stuff
you